so today i'm going to be talking about a
series of studies that we conducted at
yahoo labs trying to understand mobile
use and
if you've seen some of my other talks in
the past this is sort of very different
this isn't where we've built things and
we're running field studies of them and
seeing how people use them this is
really understanding what people are
doing today with all of the different
devices that they have in their lives
and so i'll take you through three
different studies that we ran and try to
bring that all together in the end
so as michael said i'm at the hci
research lab at yahoo where i've been
for a few years now and i've been in
corporate research now for 14 years
really kind of seeing this evolution of
mobile technology
in various ways and i do teach out at
mit we started a mobile hci class back
in 2006. so if you remember like iphone
dates and android dates that's
pre-modern smartphone and we had
students designing developing and
running field trials of unique mobile
apps
back then and still teach it which makes
for really crazy tuesdays flying back
and forth to boston
so why mobile why is this a topic that
we should study as hci researchers well
there's 7.1 billion active mobile cell
phones right now
and that is a huge number um that's 98
of the population but obviously there's
duplicates some people have two phones
or three phones or four phones but that
number is massive this is a technology
that everyone is using
in their daily lives every day
and you know a good chunk of those
connections are on fast 3g 4g networks
where rich applications and services can
really fit into people's daily lives
and mobile
is everywhere but it's also still
growing so even with that 7.1 billion
number um these are the graphs this is
you know how android is taking off how
ios is taking off and still selling
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
units
you know every year
so mobile is everywhere it's still
growing and it's growing to become a
bigger part of our day as well
this past year people are now spending
more time with the phone lit interacting
on their phone for
than they are watching television so
people are spending over three hours a
day or almost three hours a day two
hours and 57 minutes a day with the
screen on interacting with their cell
phones um and you know it's you can
watch that graph of it rise just in the
past couple years in 2012 it was only
109 minutes and now it's up to 177. so
the time we're spending on these devices
is growing exponentially
but
what are people doing on their phones
what are people doing for those three
hours a day that the screen is lit and
their face is planted in their phone
that's really where this research
started and how can we understand how
phones are actually fitting into
people's lives today
so i'll talk about a series of studies
these studies combine quantitative and
qualitative
methods and we really want to use them
to triangulate on practices really
understand not only what people are
doing but why they're doing it and how
these devices fit into their lives the
studies i'll talk about are also
somewhat longitudinal in nature they
definitely are more than just a single
interview or a single data collection
point they usually off comprise multiple
interviews some diary logging some
loggers we install on their devices to
really understand use over some period
of time
and we had a ton of research questions
when we started this work really just
from the very basic how are people using
their devices what apps are they using
how do they manage different
communication apps in their lives you
know how how are phones and tablets used
with television so while you're watching
tv what are you doing on your mobile
phones because we know that people are
using their phones a lot while they're
watching tv and then we had some
questions around people's social phone
books so the phone book on your phone
these days is not just the short list of
people you call it's really an aggregate
of all of your contacts from everywhere
on the web facebook google yahoo
linkedin whatever services you have
really all integrate into most modern
phone books right now and so we had a
lot of questions about what what those
comprise and
what those lists could be good for in
mobile applications
so why are we doing this
part of it is the academic side we are
interested in
understanding for society how phones are
impacting people's lives and what it
means to have these new devices
relatively new devices that have come
out in the last few years that people
are spending three hours a day staring
at but i also work for a company and so
obviously yahoo has a lot of interest in
understanding this as well we are
primarily a mobile app company now we
have 500 million people every month
using our mobile apps and so we want to
improve those apps we want to understand
um for contextual app recommendation in
apps like aviate our home screen how can
we get you the right app suggestion to
launch at the right time
we have large mobile search initiatives
at yahoo and how can we help you find
the right information at the right time
or even push information to you before
you even think to search for it
we have a social phone book that's out
on android and some of the work that
i'll talk about on the phone book helped
shape that product and obviously we have
a lot of different content apps so
understanding people's consumption of
things like news sports and finance on
their mobile phone can help us improve
those apps that yahoo makes
and then going beyond just improving
what we have today a lot of this work
can help build what's next and invent
new future applications services and
even devices
that better fit into people's daily
lives and interactions
so i'll talk about three studies first
i'll talk about a study we
conducted with teens to understand how
mobile apps and mobile devices fit into
their lives i'll talk about a study
where we look at phone and tv
interaction and then talk about a study
looking at the composition and use of
mobile phone books
so before i dive into any particular
study i want to talk about some of our
methods that might be a little new to
some of you
one of the big methods we use in a lot
of our studies are app loggers
this is a piece of software we put on
people's phones that keeps track of
every app that's up on the screen and
exactly when it's on the screen we don't
capture you know anything people type or
exactly what they're doing but we can
see for example in this this example
here they turned the display on they
were on their home screen for five
seconds they went into facebook for 30
seconds they went back to their home
screen for a second and then the display
went off
so these app loggers can capture
everything people do on their phones and
tablets
at this level so we can see when they're
launching apps how long they're using
them and sequences of apps as well
another method that we commonly use in
our studies are voicemail diaries so if
you just ask someone in an interview to
recall things from the past
there's often a lot of
issues in remembering exactly what
happened at what time
remembering counts of how often things
happened or exactly the specific um
the specifics around a particular
interaction so we have people during our
study call into a voicemail either every
day every couple days once a week
depending on the length of the study and
just talk a little bit about how they've
been using their device or an
application that we've given them to use
so we can get data in the middle of the
study when it's fresh in their mind and
they really remember what they did on
their device
so we'll we'll talk about how we use
those methods in each study but first
we'll talk about this teen app study
this was with some of my colleagues at
yahoo karen beverly kent and matt who is
an intern that we had from uc irvine and
this was an 18-day study of how 14
diverse teens from all over the bay area
used their mobile phone and we used a
bunch of deep qualitative and
quantitative methods that i'll get to in
a minute and we were really interested
in how they were using communication
applications because this is a category
of apps that we had presumed teens were
using a lot and in developing new
communication apps at yahoo we really
wanted to get an understanding of of
what they were doing today
the study had
five guys it had nine nine women in it
half were 13 to 15 half were 16 to 18
all over the wider bay area and they
were split between ios and android users
the method itself we started with an
initial interview because they were
teens we needed to get parental
permission uh for them to participate in
the study we showed examples of exactly
what we'd be collecting and made sure
everyone was comfortable uh with what we
were about to do
and we asked the participant about their
existing phone use we put a logger on
their phone so we could keep track of
the apps they were using over the next
18 days
and then during those 18 days we had the
teen give us a call on an 800 number and
just tell us about how they had been
using their phone that day and then we
also had the logger that was keeping
track of what they were doing and we had
a final interview where we asked some
follow-up questions based on the
voicemails trying to get more data about
specific instances that maybe they were
a little terse about or didn't talk
about exactly what we were interested in
and had some more general questions
around phone and social network use
so we collected these 18 days of logs
and that comprised for these 14 teens 79
interaction events with the phone um and
that included 34 000 app launches for
these 14 teens over over 18 days uh and
these participants were using 271 unique
applications
so they were just all over in terms of
the apps they were using we'll go into
some more detail in a moment and then
obviously we had all the qualitative
data we had interview transcripts from
the initial and final interview and all
of the voicemails
we took all the qualitative data we did
a grounded theory based affinity
analysis to find some themes in that
data that emerged we'll be discussing
those themes here in the talk
and
really understanding deeply how they
were using these services and how they
fit into their lives
they were spending about three hours a
day
interacting with their phone with the
phone lit
and over two hours a day in particular
applications so the other hour was time
spent in the home screen or the settings
or the
the lock screen on the phone
and the average times in a particular
app was about a minute
so these are very quick interactions
and we'll give a breakdown in a minute
of what some of the longer or shorter
app categories were
but this this use is very bursty i mean
every one minute in an app but they're
using apps 136 minutes a day
which is quite a lot they were using a
lot of apps on average they had 36
unique apps and a range of 22 to 64. so
even the teen who was using the fewest
apps was using 22 different apps in
their lives over these over these two
weeks
an average of 129 app launches a day
um
and so that when you start to think
about this this is a huge number 129
launches of particular applications and
they were using 15 different app
categories so things like social
networking news email all of those are
in different app categories
so those are just some of the raw
numbers but how did the use really fit
into the pattern of the day
this is this is just the number of app
launches in each hour so you can see for
a lot of these teens they woke up pretty
early 6 7 a.m started using their
devices but they get a huge spike after
school most high schoolers end school
around 3 p.m and so you can see this
huge spike in abuse coming at the end of
the school day and continuing you know
well into the night to 10 pm or so and
that's really their core interaction
time with the phone
but what are they doing in those times
so this is looking at different app
categories and when in the day people
are using the apps so the blue at the
top those are all the communication apps
and you can see that just 3 pm they
start and they're communicating like
crazy 3 pm to 10 pm that's really their
heavy use time
for communications applications
you can see some sort of obvious things
like the weather app gets used in the
morning 6 7 a.m when they get up and
then not used at all maybe a little bit
at the end of the day to check whether
uh the education 6a um that was it's an
app that was actually not used very much
i have another table that shows um
numbers for each of these but the
education category was hardly ever used
it could have been uh to check like this
the uh grades or their schedule for the
school
um but that was a category that was not
used quite as much
i don't think it's many instances
there's not that many instances that's
what i'm saying so maybe it's an app
that was launched five times or ten
times right it was launched six times at
six am and four times at eight pm um
yeah but i have another table that can
can show you some of the categories but
i think the main things to take away
from this is you know communications is
happening later in the day
and some other categories are at
specific times like weather in the
morning and things like that
one of the things we were most intrigued
by was that the phone is still primarily
a phone despite using these dozens of
different apps every day the top apps
are sms and phone calls
and
you know even for teens who you think
are using all these other communication
apps and they're not really using these
core features of the phone um the core
phone apps were the most used among the
teens and then you see the other kind of
social apps instagram snapchat twitter
facebook all of that appearing in the
middle here
but the main apps are still the main
phone apps
that's one launcher close it and open up
it again that would count as two
launches yeah yeah
we'll also talk a little bit about
duration in a minute um but right now
we're just talking about particular
launches of the app which generally
means you're on the home screen and you
hit the icon and it opens up the app
doesn't i mean
don't you really mean visits because
apps can live in the background and you
can just open it up again well we count
that as a separate launch
so yeah
yeah so revisiting an app is a separate
logic
yeah anytime that something else was on
the screen and then the app comes back
then we're counting that as a launch
whether it comes from the home screen or
the recent apps or a notification
yeah you could have done yeah
um so if we start looking at durations
of app use and here you can see some of
the counts for each of the categories
but you can see that the apps that
people are using for longer periods of
time
you can see games travel entertainment
media
news magazines these are the apps that
are you know the teens were spending two
three minutes in per interaction
and you can see things like the contact
list uh the phone um email these were
very short interactions uh certainly in
comparison to some of the media based
interactions
um that are that are towards the bottom
so this is looking how different
categories of apps really fit into
people's lives and here you can see by
category the social networking apps
were more heavily used in the one to
five minute range so if you think of
facebook kind of scrolling through the
feed seeing everything if you think of
instagram liking photos uploading your
own photos these are things that that
would engage them for for much longer
periods of time than really quick
interactions like with the contact list
right most contact list interactions
were less than five seconds you open it
you hit somebody
that's near the top and you're done and
you're in the phone book or you're in
the you're in a phone call or you're in
an sms message
so what we saw with these teens is it
really is all about communication for
them two-thirds of their time spent in
apps was spent in communication related
apps and so these are just all the top
apps and you can see all of them except
browsers and
pandora are communication related apps
and this is really what they're using
their phones for and they're using an
average of 9.4 different communication
apps per participant in the study so
they don't have just the go-to every
time they communicate it's sms they're
using sms they're using instagram
they're using snapchat they're using
twitter they're using facebook they're
using all these different apps in their
lives for different purposes and so that
was something we were really interested
in digging into in the qualitative data
james
the date of the study it was um
late 2013 yeah
is there any
um they think might be a big change from
them and now or i would expect the usage
to even go up from then um if you look
at the general phone
the distribution of apps i would expect
facebook to fall even more
even in our study the teens were already
telling us that's how i communicate with
my aunt and uncle um and that's not how
you know they would communicate with
their friends so i'd expect that to fall
a little more
i would expect maybe whatsapp to start
to show up here where it wasn't showing
up at all in late 2013 but i still
expect the percentage of communication
apps to probably stay about the same
um and that's really what they what they
were doing with the the bulk of their
time
so as i said we were really interested
in the qualitative data and digging in
why are they using particular apps and
snapchat was something we were
particularly interested in because it
was very much on the rise in 2013
when we ran the study and we ran it
towards the end of 2013 um so we got we
were asking teens a lot about why they
were using it what they were doing with
it and they would tell us that
they don't want a history and they don't
they want some way where they can just
feel like they're sharing something with
a friend no one's going to record it and
it will just go away and so you know
someone one of the participants told the
snapchat is so temporary i don't care
what the picture is of it's my closest
friends you know we send ugly pictures
of ourselves we make funny faces we do
something stupid and the teens don't
feel that there's any repercussion for
capturing that and sharing it with each
other
and that leads into why they're not
using facebook as much um our
participant two told us i don't use
facebook it leads to too many problems
in your life you post one thing on there
it's never going to go away um and they
really feel that you know even if they
try to manage who can see it someone
will end up seeing it because some
setting is not configured right or
somebody will forward it beyond their
control and they really feel that using
that platform could get them in trouble
later in life and these kind of goofy
pictures they're sending to each other
um could be used against them and that's
something that probably has been drilled
into them by teachers and parents and be
careful what you put online and that's
one reason that these these categories
of applications that are much more
ephemeral and don't keep a lasting
profile are becoming more popular for
them
and we see that for sites that have a
lasting profile these teens were taking
so much effort to craft the perfect post
and to get the perfect picture together
p12 was on the softball team in her high
school and they were all taking pictures
during this one game and they got
together after the game and spent like
half an hour putting a collage together
and getting all the right pictures and
getting them at the right angles and
getting everything that where everyone
looks perfect in the picture and she was
also telling us we're just like well
what did you do with the other pictures
and she's like oh yeah we snapchatted
those back and forth like crazy ones
where they were all muddy and dirty and
looking looking not the way they wanted
to portray themselves on instagram or on
facebook
so that was really interesting to us how
how much effort they put into crafting
something that was perfect to put out
there for other people to see and they
would also tell us if they posted a
photo and nobody liked it within a few
minutes they would take it down
and multiple teens in the study were
telling us about this practice how if
you don't get that immediate social
validation you don't want the
embarrassment of having a photo that has
no likes and so they spend so much
effort crafting it and then if it
doesn't hit it it's gone and they'll
remove it almost immediately
in fact one of the participants she's
like yeah my friend called me and said i
really need to take my picture down
because it's been up too long and
nobody's liking it and so even their
friends were watching out for them you
know nobody's liking your photo make
sure you take it away um and that was
just this amazing behavior that that we
heard again and again from our
participants
the other thing we saw is snapchatting
being used in in a mass communication
way
and multiple of our participants were
using it this way as well they would
take a picture this one participant was
going off to college and she was packing
to go down to la and she took this photo
of her room kind of all empty because
she had put everything in her suitcase
and mass snapchatted it and that's the
word she used for this behavior
to everybody to anyone she had friended
on snapchat so she didn't want to post
it to facebook she's like it's just
that's too much but she just wanted a
bunch of people to see it and just have
it go away and not kind of have that
memory of the empty home lingering
around on the internet
another thing we looked at was
coordination and what apps the teens
were using to coordinate with each other
most of the time they were using sms
because that's an app everyone has if
you have an iphone if you have an
android it doesn't matter you can sms
with each other you know it's going to
get through
at least you're pretty confident it's
going to get through and it works with
everyone
one of the other things we saw is these
are teens they get their phones taken
away by their parents
and many of them had ipod touches that
they were allowed to use if their phone
got taken away and so they would use kik
then the whole group would switch to kik
for the duration that their friend had
their phone taken away because they
could use kik without a sim card um and
some parents would actually just steal
the sim card from their kids phones and
not actually take away the phone so it
would still work on wi-fi um and then
they would switch to kik because they
don't have you know the sms capability
on the phone
and we talked to them a bit about phone
calls and again and again the
participants were like yeah that's you
know if you have an objective to
complete you will make a phone call if
your mom is supposed to pick you up and
she's not there you make a phone call or
if you need to plan an exact arrival
time of something you make a phone call
but for the most part the phone for the
the actual phone you talk on for these
participants was
sort of a
not something they would just do on a
regular basis they weren't calling each
other and talking to each other on the
phone very much
sometimes they'd use skype they'd do
group skypes videos hangouts things like
that
but they weren't actually spending much
time chatting on the phone with each
other
another theme that came out of our
analysis was using the phone just to
pass time and feeling like you almost
have this compulsion to keep using the
phone and you know i'm walking home
alone i'm bored i'm just going to play
games or text people you know if you're
bored you can go watch netflix things
like that that the phone was just this
this device that could fill the the the
spare time that they had and could
really just kind of grow to fill
whatever amount of time they had where
they weren't interacting with others or
working on their schoolwork and things
like that but they were actually very
aware that they were spending a lot of
time on their phone and we asked one of
our participants about games and she's
like oh i never play candy crush i was
tempted to but my roommate lost her life
doing that she's on it all the time it's
so addicting and so so participants in
the study really knew that there were
some things that probably they should
stay away from
and might really
end up taking too much of their time and
distracting
so key takeaways from this study the
teens were using their phones about
three hours a day which was ahead of the
general population at that time you know
a year and a few months ago
specific apps are more common at certain
times of day or at certain locations
the teens are very actively considering
the ephemerality in the audience when
they're choosing a communication service
it's not that they just have a go-to app
and that's how they communicate they
really think what is this going to
reflect on me in the future and they
will spend a lot of time crafting a
perfect post for something that's going
to have a profile where they can just
use snapchat to share these moments with
each other i'm curious what the
distribution of behaviors was amongst
the teens like did you find that most
teens were using it around three hours a
day or was there a wide variety in the
amount of time people were spending on
their phone to what they're doing it's
actually it was quite uniform i think
the lowest was like
don't quote me on the particular numbers
but i feel like the lowest was around
like 1.8 hours a day or so and then we
had somebody who was up around four
but it was yeah it was within that range
they were all really using their phones
quite a lot
and you know maybe day to day it varies
or weekday weekend it varies a little
bit but they were all very much tied to
their devices
we also saw that you know teens are
frequently rebuilding new networks on
new services instead of curating lists
on existing services we talked to them a
bit about you know like how do you would
you ever defriend people or like no no
we just moved to the next app
so you know they'll move to snapchat and
build a new network on snapchat and then
they don't have to worry about curating
the network they had on facebook that
they don't really use anymore
which was quite interesting to us and
they desire communication platforms that
anyone can use regardless of device and
that's why sms is still the number one
app among every teen in our study sms
was their go-to communication app
so moving on a bit from teens
we just finished another study this fall
looking at combined phone tablet use
with television and you know the second
screen and using mobile devices uh while
watching tv has become
a big media buzzword recently um
twitter is being heavily promoted during
television shows mainly because networks
want you to watch it live which means
you watch the commercials
but they're heavily promoting the use of
hashtags and the use of twitter during
tv programming
and there are survey studies that show
people report using their mobile devices
a lot while they watch tv
but there's really not much data on what
exactly they're doing beyond people
checking a box like i use it for
shopping or i use it for email or i use
it for for these categories of things
so we wanted to investigate this we
wanted to see what phone and tablet use
looks like during tv watching how often
are people using their devices are there
differences when the programs are on and
when the commercials are on are there
differences between different genres
what apps are used most frequently when
people are watching tv
and then why are they doing this um is
it that the tv show isn't compelling
enough to keep their full attention are
they using it during commercials or
lulls in the shows to keep themselves
busy um you know why why is this this
phenomena really happening
so this was a bit of a complex setup um
because we wanted to unders we wanted to
capture all of this data to really have
a ground truth of what they were doing
so yahoo is a service called into now
it's basically like shazam but for tv
shows um so we took a mobile phone and
we just put it underneath their
television and so this was listening
to the ambient audio in the room and it
would on device capture a fingerprint
that it would then try to match on the
server so we weren't storing any raw
audio or anything of what was going on
in the living room but it was capturing
a fingerprint every 30 seconds of what
they were watching on tv if it was a
commercial if it was a tv show what show
it was um so we had a ground truth of tv
watching in the home and then we placed
ble bluetooth low energy beacons
throughout the home and our app logger
on the phone we modified to look at the
signal strength to the ble beacons and
so now we knew what room of the home
they were in with fairly high accuracy
and if they were home or if they were
away from the home
so we would know you're in the living
room the tv is on you're watching this
show and you're using these particular
apps on your phone
so bit of a complex setup but it got us
all the data that we needed
and the the study was structured much
like the previous one we had an initial
interview we set up everything in their
home
for two weeks we had them have a
voicemail diary just about how they were
using their devices we didn't ask for a
specific um commentary around television
use we were hoping that that would come
out a bit naturally
from the data and then we had a final
interview where we asked questions and
follow-ups based on the logs and based
on the voicemails that we got
so what did we what did we get we
captured a bunch of phone use a bunch of
tablet use
we saw that half of all phone use was at
home
and that eighteen percent of phone use
at home was while watching television uh
which is a was was fairly interesting to
us we we captured all the shows they
were watching uh they were watching uh
about 21 of their shows were 30 minutes
long a little bit more were one hour
long shows a variety of genres so we
feel like we collected a nice amount of
data
that we could then start looking at
so when did they interact we were
expecting to see
big spikes in phone use during
commercials this is what people often
self-report doing
but we actually did not see that at all
we saw very little difference actually
between
phone use during programs and phone use
during commercials
and this could be because you know
people are
other you know they use the commercial
times to go to the kitchen or go to the
bathroom or go do other things um
but um we found that quite interesting
we also found it interesting that 25 of
the time the tv is on they're using
their phone and tablet
so that is a significant amount of the
tv program where they are engaged on a
second device and presumably not
watching the tv as much
we saw some differences in genres so
comedy drama sports
events or non-events not events or
things like sportscenter or things like
that
people were using their devices quite a
lot of the time 60 70 percent of the
time
while that show was on some device was
being used um whereas the more like
documentary science news magazine
history nature things like that um the
device was not being used as much and so
that was was fairly interesting to us
that those those shows that you kind of
have to pay attention to because they're
actually telling you something
informative um you're not actually
interacting with the device as much uh
whereas things like sports where you
could zone out for half an hour and not
missed something maybe in a soccer match
you know people were very heavily
engaged with their devices and we'll get
into some of the motivations for for
using it in a moment john did you have a
question whether you accounted for
multiple people watching tv and multiple
devices like sometimes
i'm on my phone while my wife's watching
something.tv were you able to take that
in the data well yes and we'll talk
quite a bit about that in the
qualitative data and that is one reason
that the use is so high is people are
not interested in the show at all but
they want to be with their family member
who is watching something that they care
about um more on that in like three
slides um one thing that we found was
really interesting was these looking at
reality shows and crime dramas these are
shows where something big happens at the
end
someone gets kicked off they find the
murderer someone's convicted right
the phone use which are the bars drops
substantially for the last 10 minutes of
the show um for both crime dramas and
reality shows so people are kind of
zoning out they're doing their thing
while the show is on and then in the
last 10 minutes they put their phone
down and they're like okay what's gonna
happen like this is the interesting part
of the show um so we found that to be to
be quite interesting in looking at what
they were doing
but that's a lot on what and the
quantitative but why are they doing this
um and here's to john's point
repeatedly people were telling us i want
to be in the same room as my family
member they're they're really excited
about survivor i hate it but i want to
be with them right so i'm going to sit
on the couch with them and i'm going to
play on my tablet or i'm going to play
on my phone or i'm going to do the bills
or i'm going to do something but i want
to be seated next to them
and that we heard that again and again
and again from our participants is they
were not actively watching the show it
was someone else in the household who
was really excited about it
um
we also saw people like doing chores
paying bills
things like that during the show and we
saw all the other times where the tv was
just background noise and this is you
know known in tv literature the tv is
often on in the home and nobody's really
watching and we saw this around sporting
events sometimes you know this one
participant says oh i'm watching
basketball i can hear what's going on i
don't have to be looking at it you know
the announcer will start to get excited
in his voice if something's about to
happen and i'll look up um so they can
be doing something else on their phone
and just kind of hearing the game um
and other people said you know if i
wasn't particularly engaged in whatever
we're watching you know i'm checking
email on my phone when i'm doing other
things
so the tv program is
often not the focus of attention and
it's just kind of there as some
background to have something going on
in the
home we found that very little of their
device use was actually related to the
show they were watching so this is
something that all the second screen
hype is you know you're interacting with
people on twitter you're talking about
the show you're looking up brands you're
doing all of this stuff related to the
program now this doesn't really happen
um it happens to some amount but this
isn't the majority of use the majority
of use is facebook and and and email and
texting and just sort of the standard
mundane phone usage
but we did see a few instances
this one person was watching a
razorback's game and they didn't have
the stat he wanted to see he was a big
sports guy he wanted a stat at this
moment in the show and it wasn't in the
broadcast so he took out his phone and
he opened up the cbs sports app and
found the stat he was looking for
other people who had fantasy sports
teams were often checking the fantasy
team and their score in the fantasy team
as things went on as well
and we did find one example of shopping
uh there was a commercial that showed a
car that this this little toy car that
her daughter really liked and they
actually went online and found it and
bought it like within a few minutes of
the commercial happening um so this kind
of stuff does happen people do get
inspired by what's going on on the tv
and they go off and find something but
you know i we really had to hunt to find
these examples to actually talk about
related things people were doing um it's
really often these these non-related
uses that that are occurring
so some of the implications from this
study um first of all understanding
people and their behaviors is is really
interesting in its own right um you know
television is such a big part of our
lives three hours a day now phones are a
big part of our lives three hours a day
how do those work together how are how
is the act of watching television
changing now that we have these mobile
devices and you might argue that well
somebody else might have just taken the
newspaper or the magazine and sat on the
couch with them before and now they have
a mobile device and so that's what
they're using to replace that so i think
some of this is
just new ways to do old behaviors um but
some of this is certainly new
experiences that are enabled by all the
rich capabilities of a mobile phone that
are now in people's lives
another implication technology is often
or the television is often just
background noise and now mobile phones
allow you to do a lot more while that's
on we even saw people watching youtube
videos while they were watching tv
and we asked them about this and they're
just like yeah well what was going on on
the tv wasn't that exciting and somebody
mentioned a video so we brought it up
and we played it and that got us
watching other youtube videos and they
spent half an hour watching youtube
videos while another program was playing
on their television
so that those kinds of things are
happening the tv is often just this
background thing that's that's playing
something that might be of mild interest
yeah
did you monitor uh when the tv was
running and mute it because so we were
not
able to capture when the tv was muted uh
we were using the sound printing
technology so that the tv had to be on
um
for us to capture it uh we're i don't
know how common muting the television is
um
and i don't even know any data set where
i could easily find that answer um but
yeah it was only when the audio was on
did you stretch your participants to not
mute or anything like that no no we
didn't want them to change their
behaviors at all we basically said we're
going to put these loggers on just to
see what you do
just do what you would do and
that's how i start almost all of my
studies is tell people
you're not required to use this in any
way even when we build a new prototype
and give it to someone we're just saying
pretend you just downloaded this from
the app store if you don't like it don't
use it if you like it and it fits in
your life use it um you know we we want
you to just go about your life as if
we're not logging anything
and yeah it's you know
people will modify their behaviors
because they're in a study to some
degree
but if you give them those reassurances
up front we've seen that people are much
more honest in their use
and you know we've run studies and seen
everyone stops using it and we're just
like great this app is not useful for
people and we'll get some you know data
in the interviews about why um but we've
seen other ones where we tell them we
don't care if you use it they use it
five times a day for four months and
then we're like great we're on to
something here um and so that's that's
an important part of our methods in a
lot of the studies that we run
and then for hci
if we can measure engagement in the show
versus engagement in mobile devices that
could be very important for pricing
advertising if you know people aren't
paying attention to a reality show until
the last 10 minutes
that can be really important in various
types of advertising
it can be used to help content creators
uh to keep programming more compelling
or to do things to to get people to pay
more attention to the tv uh while the
show is going
and also if we understand interactions
on some of these related things like
getting more sports stats and things
like that that can help us create better
sports applications and get people the
kind of stats and information they need
without having to go hunt in an app and
find what they're looking for and go to
a certain game if the tv and the phone
can be more in parallel and know what's
going on on each other's device we can
provide a lot more contextual
information for people
so the final study i wanted to talk
about is looking at people's mobile
phone books and like i said at the start
mobile phone books now are often social
phone books especially on android most
mobile phone books combine sources from
you know facebook gmail yahoo linkedin
uh twitter all these different services
to create one giant contact list and
i'm responsible for this happening back
at motorola we created the first social
phone book that did this back in 2007
and it's really caught on it's what
people are using and
this is really what's what's out in the
world today but nobody's really studied
how people use these things um we made
it at motorola and for various reasons
we didn't end up studying much about
what people were doing with it and so
now i decided great it's a good chance
let's revisit this space now that this
is pervasive and see what people are
doing
and this is important because a bunch of
mobile apps are now using the contact
list on the phone
as a list of trusted contacts if you
download a new app it often goes to your
phone book and tries to auto-friend
people in your phone book
to say these are trusted people you
could communicate with some apps even
turn on location sharing for anyone in
your phone book so they can see where
you are at a city level or a
neighborhood level and this really
freaked us out because we know what
these contact lists are now and there's
all these people in them so we wanted to
really understand who are these people
and are these really trusted contacts
mobile phone books are now you know like
i said this aggregation of all these
different contexts together and we were
building a social phone book product at
yahoo that was released around christmas
time and so we were interested the study
was done last summer in helping them
design that and build that that new
phone book app that we were making and
we really don't have an understanding of
of who's in a phone book or who people
communicate with
so we did an online survey um we had
people install an app on their phone
that would upload their phone book um
but not any of the contact information
just the names um
and like a hash of the contact
information so we could dedupe uh things
to our server and it would also upload
the sms history
the times that they communicated with
those people as well as the lengths of
the messages not the actual messages and
it would upload the phone call history
with those people as well
and then we had an online survey that
would pick 25 random contacts out of
their whole list and ask them a bunch of
questions you know who is this person
are they a friend a colleague when did
you communicate with them
would you share various kinds of things
with them and how close do you feel to
them and some general demographic
questions at the end
we had a really nice representative
sample for this we had 200 participants
from across the u.s from 35 states 18 to
64 half female
33 college graduates really fitting in
with the the us demographic in many ways
we collected a total of information
about 65 000 different contacts and we
got detailed survey questions that
people answered about almost 5 000
contacts and we captured call logs for
almost 75 000 calls and hundreds of
thousands of sms messages
so we really got to look at how people
were communicating with the people in
their contact lists
so how big is a contact list
any guesses on the average
yeah
300 300 is is pretty darn good so an
average of 308 contacts
but a median of 165. so there were a
bunch of people that were in the 100 to
200 range that's kind of where the bulk
was um but we had these these crazy
outliers um people up to 3000 contacts
uh in their phone book and so even with
a couple hundred people that's probably
more than your trusted set of of
contacts um you know with 300 people so
who are these people
well 22 of them are your friends that's
okay you got a bunch of colleagues some
family some friends of friends some
schoolmates acquaintances
people you used to date exes um we were
very interested in that especially
around auto sharing right do you want to
auto share your location with someone
you used to date
no
but a lot of systems do that if they're
still in your phone book right what was
most interesting to us here is the final
bar we had a an option of i don't know
who this person is
and 29 of the contacts in your phone
book if you're asked at random about
them you have no idea who they are you
do not recognize them by name
um and that's because of this aggregate
like someone friended you on linkedin
five years ago that you ran into at a
conference
you don't remember you might not
remember their name right um and so a
lot of people in our phone books we
don't actually know who they are
who do we actually communicate with
84 of all calls went to five people 81
of all sms's went to five people this is
our core network these are the people we
communicate with most often um and so
you might have a list of 300 people but
there's five people you really talk to
on a regular basis
so what would people want to share with
these contacts
what we found really interesting was it
wasn't the type of information that you
were sharing it was really who that
person was that mattered in your
willingness to share with them you might
say this is obvious but there's a lot of
people who for years have been saying
like location is really sensitive but
you know free busy in a calendar is not
and things like that what we found at
least from from this self-reported data
of would you be comfortable sharing this
information with this individual person
um was that it really you know with your
partner yeah you share pretty much
anything with a colleague you probably
don't want to share some of this stuff
with a business so like your thai food
restaurant that you order food from down
the street you really don't want to
share stuff with right um
but they're in your phone book right so
if it's like a cell phone with somebody
at the store they're gonna see your
location if you're in one of these apps
that auto shares location
um and then what kind of app would you
want to be auto-friended with these
people uh in in the um in your phone
book um you know your partner yeah they
autofriend in a chat app or a music app
or a location app that's probably okay
but a colleague especially in a location
app you know probably not you don't want
to be auto-friended and share that
automatically um
you know acquaintances probably not as
much but family yeah you know that's
okay for some of them um
so that was really interesting to us
because like i said a lot of these
applications are using your whole phone
book as this list of trusted contacts
and that is not how people feel about
the people in this big giant list uh and
so that's really important for anybody
building one of these
yeah
that's just businesses
yeah businesses so yeah
you know restaurants shops i think
people like the post office or their
bank or things like that were some
examples and john did you correlate the
answers to these questions with that
frequency data that you have
i.e
you you can automatically know frequency
and then you could say would you be able
to share this with the five most
frequent people
we didn't but i'm gonna do that tonight
yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's actually a study from
carnegie mellon that looked at that and
showed that the people you contact
frequently are likely to be high tie
strength
but the people you don't contact
frequently are not necessarily low tie
strength
yeah
so i would probably say that this this
correlates quite well with the the
people you contact the most
but the cmu paper is also a pretty good
source on some of that
so a couple more things about what these
phone books look like
if you're trying to match people across
multiple services they need to have real
names
if i want to say james landay is on
twitter as james landay on facebook is
james landay and my phone book they all
need to be named james landay or
something very close to that
you might do nickname matching and find
a gym or something like that but um you
know
that's um you know that's kind of the
extent of what you can actually do
programmatically and automatically
but
um 74 only 74 of all contacts that were
not just email addresses had a space in
the name so 26 only had one single
word um so it could be mom it could be
dad it could be james it could be david
it could be whatever but it's just one
word
but then we said well what do these two
word ones look like are they all names
and no they're not people were using
things like my wife or my handsome
husband or mom and dad or boyfriend
heart
and this is what their contacts were
named so again if you're trying to build
one of these phone book systems or if
you're trying to use these names as
invitations
to invite people to a service how would
you feel if you got an invitation that
said hi stinky
well your friend you know
james wanted to invite you to this to
this um application
probably not what you would want to do
um so again if you're if you're trying
to use phone book data
if you're trying to use phone book data
for these sorts of uses
you might want to think twice or at
least look to try to see if it matches
common names or something like that
or someone might be surprised um they
might not know that you're calling them
stinky in your phone book
um so what were people's kind of initial
reactions to
seeing this data and participating in
the survey we had some open response
things at the end and for almost
everyone they were shocked at
all of the people that were in their
contact lists and
especially the fact that they didn't
recognize so many of them and some
people talked about like oh i should go
clean this up and some people even like
left some nice things like oh i tried to
clean my contacts once and then
everybody came back
because these services try to sync right
so the next time you get a new phone
it's going to pull your facebook list in
again right and so people were giving up
and people were just like yeah well it's
a big list and that's what i get right
that's how phones work these days um but
in general people were very surprised
that that so many folks were brought
into their contact list
so what does this mean
it means that phone book and messaging
apps first of all need to make it really
simple to contact your most frequently
contacted people if you just have a
simple top five people that's going to
get you know over 80 of calls and
messages and you don't even have to deal
with the long list um systems should
assume that not all contacts are trusted
you know 29 are completely unknown so
probably auto friending everybody in
there not a great idea automatically
sharing location with everybody in there
definitely not a good idea yet these are
things that services are trying to do
these days and and are getting some
pushback uh from folks
how many of those contacts were actually
duplicates
you know when i asked these
services together like if i look up jane
monday in my own contacts i
have ten yeah and any
person i know there's multiple times
coming from the different servers
so we didn't we didn't have a good way
to get at that with the method because
we only asked about 25 random contacts
so the likelihood of getting a duplicate
in there is pretty small um
and most of the android phone books
these days at least try to merge if
there's an exact match
so even going through some of the logs
manually like they'd be different i
wouldn't know that you know a john and a
john tong are the same person looking at
that later so we didn't really have a
good sense of what percent don't don't
combine um accurately um
back when we were doing moto blur we saw
that there were probably about 20 30 or
so that would not combine um even with
kind of the best data sources and trying
to match on email phone number or name
um there were still 20 to 30 that just
wouldn't match because you don't have
enough information in each one
to find the overlaps
so manual matching is often necessary
because a lot of contacts don't have
proper names like i said 26 of contacts
here have only a first name uh so that
gets to some of the you know not not
being able to match
and it should be really easy to remove
people from phone books or at least not
make them visible there are probably
reasons why you want to have a big list
of everyone you've ever contacted or
connected to but kind of the default
thing when you want to go make a phone
call probably shouldn't be that list of
a thousand people
or an average of 300 people um and
showing people you're actually likely to
call probably is is a much better list
to show yeah why
because you have to scroll through a
thousand people that's going to take you
forever
i'm not immediately convinced that
people treat this as a browsing
experience so when you're when you're
going to call someone you have to find
them right
very few people use search in their
mobile phone book yeah
most people will swipe to find the
person they're looking for
we have some quantitative data on up but
yes that most people will will swipe to
find the contact and like android has
the swipe to letter so you can like get
to the g's but then you might have 80
g's and you have to find the one you're
looking for i mean i have a top five to
seven contacts it's my recent calls
that's usually where i've been it's not
so in our paper we have a high paper on
this and we actually look at the
difference between reasons and frequency
and there's actually not so much overlap
because you get a lot of random incoming
calls or outgoing calls like you'll call
the thai food place or you'll call
somebody else and that's not
your most frequent so it's the frequent
list that is really the most useful list
over the recent list there's more on
that in the paper
that is like
wouldn't that depend a little bit if you
think of your recent calls it's kind of
like a cash like what eviction pause
you're using like if you know you get a
call from some stranger yeah delete that
number and then keep the like people you
actually call it sooner it's like yeah
can you manually there are things you
could do to maybe to maybe do that but
you might actually want to call that
random person back so there's this whole
concept of temporary contacts where it's
someone who's like really important in
your life for like an hour or a day
right like today michael's number is
really handy to me right tomorrow
there's a lower likelihood that i'm
going to call him right
yeah certainly we will talk in the
future so i don't want to delete his
name right but you know it's there's a
higher likelihood it's you're on a
soccer team with a bunch of people for
three months and then you're not right
um so that's that's interesting
so we made a phone book at yahoo we had
this kind of top contacts up here your
were your people eye contact that would
look at folks that you contact
frequently and put them up at the top we
would also auto hide
under each letter the people you've
never contacted um so if we have no
communication history with that person
they go away um so you get a much
shorter contact list and those 29
percent of people you don't even know
who they are
are not in the list and there's a way to
expand it and see everybody but by
default those are people you just don't
need to contact so going back to one of
the takeaways we had from two slides ago
where it sounded like where i saw a bit
of a parallel where uh you kind of have
this contact sheet for this contact us
which is almost like a network of people
that we've sort of outgrown and if it
was if we were like referencing back to
the team use like this would almost be
one of those cases where people would
have moved on to another thing and
instead of curating their old list they
would just come up with a new one yeah
we're so entrenched in phones that we
just can't get away from it so this is
sort of a weird anomalous phenomenon
where we're stuck with this like
sprawling contact yes and now it sounds
like you're trying to create a new uh
almost like a new room is trying to
filter out the older people yeah yeah um
and you can still get to them if you
want to but the idea is they they've
moved you've moved on right um you know
you don't need to call your college
roommate anymore but he might still be
in your phone book um and maybe you want
to call them maybe
i see the face you might want to right
but there are just people when you move
on in life that you just don't talk to
anymore um and that's just kind of how
life works
um so there's more information in a kai
paper that we have upcoming i'm happy to
send anyone an advanced copy if they
want more
and then just to sum up here today
some of the key takeaways from from all
of these studies people are using their
mobile devices a ton three hours a day
with the screen lit
they're using a ton of different
communication applications and teens
especially are really thinking about the
visibility and permanence of content
before they post it to new services
television is not this attention
commanding device that maybe it once was
the family gathering around the tv with
their eyes glued on the set
is not what's happening 25 percent of
the time that the tv is on people are
using their devices and touching and
clicking and and doing things on their
phones and tablets
but mobile devices allow people to be
physically together in the tv room even
if particular folks aren't interested in
the show that's on the tv
and then with the phone books we've seen
that we've aggregated all these people
from all over the web but in doing so
we've made a list where 29 of people are
completely unknown uh to the user
and so it's not appropriate to auto
friend or auto share with everyone in
the phone book
thinking a bit about some of the methods
none of these studies would have really
been possible with only quantitative
data we had we couldn't just look at
logs and get this kind of analysis we
had to combine deep qualitative and
quantitative methods to really build up
this picture of what people were doing
and why they were doing it and so
combining things like interviews diary
studies and app loggers could give us
all this rich data that we couldn't get
with any of those techniques by
themselves
but are we spending too much of our time
looking at our screens you know three
hours a day that's a lot of time that
we're not looking at each other that
we're not looking at our environments
that we're not
active in the places where we are and
i think that's that's kind of
disappointing um i think we should be
doing more to to limit the time we're
staring at screens in our lives and so
there's a lot of ways you can think
about doing this you could think about
things that bring
shorter interactions glanceable things
on wearables or limiting notifications
we had a nice conversation at lunch
about this
thinking of ways to only interrupt
people when something really needs their
attention and not when they have a
groupon email come into their their
gmail or something like that um those
kinds of things are are important but i
i mean i grew up with the tradition of
ubiquitous computing i was at mit in the
late 90s when this was was a big topic
and so i think maybe pushing internet
information into our environment might
be a solution where we don't have to be
staring at these devices and
so this is a hack day project that i did
with a colleague at yahoo on chengxu and
we basically said what if we took the
yahoo weather app and made it physical
um
and so we've got the beautiful little
flicker photos and we can spin them
around to different cities we have the
sun come up through the sky like it does
in the weather app and we've got the
temperature on a little thermometer out
in the front and so if we had more
information in our environments if we
had more
glanceable displays and ways to
just see information without distracting
us from what we were doing
i believe this could really limit a lot
of the time that we're spending staring
at our screens
and that could be a compelling way
forward three hours a day does that
include people working because you know
some people use google for work such as
facebook sometimes sms i mean it's all
you know how because i feel like a lot
of people do spend a lot of time on
phones for work
yes um and so this is total use um so
some of it can be work related some of
it can be not work related um
i do have a count someplace of like use
in the evening versus use during the day
but obviously used in the evening for a
lot of people is work as well um
but yeah that is that is time staring at
the small screens in our lives
uh yeah communication apps i think you
lumped together things that are
bi-directional right like sms with
things that are like viewing primarily
right twitter and facebook right um
how like if you subdivide the that like
how does that break down is it primarily
um that like the three so the top ones
were still the
bi-directional so sms was you know
double anything else on the phone 20
percent of all phone use was sms
does this ambient display vision of
yours really make sense like most of the
time you need to be responding anyhow
well so that's still only 20 of the time
you're an sms there's still you know
large amounts of time you're in other
services
and even for sms right like if someone's
contacting you there have been all sorts
of neat ambient displays made over the
years to kind of show priority and show
kind of how much is waiting for you and
and how much you really need to respond
to
um if you knew there was something in
your environment that would get your
attention when you needed it whether
it's in your environment just like on a
watch or a wearable or something or it's
actually um
in in in your home on a shelf you know
maybe you could look at ways like that
to to help interrupt people there's a
lot of work in business settings done in
the late 90s early 2000s ibm had this
kind of office of the future concept
that tried to have little displays to
show when things that needed your
attention were were available so there's
a lot that could be revisited there as
well
but i will take more questions inside i
just want to thank all of my
collaborators on all this work before i
forget to do that so i want to thank
beverly karen kent matt christian matash
ying-yu and chung who were all involved
in the studies and devices that i showed
here today and now i'm happy to take any
questions for the next 10 minutes
yeah
how much were you like watching her heat
into like um sort of attentiveness like
maybe from like screen touches or
whatever like
right because that three hours isn't
usually actually three hours so there's
some like i don't know there's some
multitasking some switching like i don't
know the number of people in this room
are like simultaneously using their
phones and paying attention to the
conversation right like yeah like how do
you start looking at something so we
didn't go to the level of capturing
screen touches um there are apis in
android that will let you do that but
you also then by definition have their
passwords and have the content of their
messages if you if you would analyze it
that way and we'd prefer just not to
have that data i don't want to have that
data on a server someplace where if
someone got to it they could get at
people's very very personal data
so you could i mean you could capture
just time of capture and not position um
if you logged everything right and threw
things away on the device right um
and then you could get at how often are
they touching the screen but those were
three hours of active screen on time so
if you think it's screen has a timeout
of 10 to 30 seconds depending on the
default you know they're touching it uh
for almost all of that time
i was just thinking like demographic
just differences in terms of what of
that you're studying the study
like you know with some more
economic things like digital things
when we recruit participants for our
studies especially smaller ones where we
might only have a dozen people in it or
so
we generally use professional recruiting
firms and get the broadest demographic
sample we can get because if we start
seeing trends across very very different
people in very very different life
situations it's more likely that we're
on to something that will be valid for
the broader population so we had people
you know
unfortunately it's easy to run a study
in the bay area because i live here so
we do pick bay area folks but we go
in the broadest definition of the bay
area as possible where we were up in up
near davis for some of our participants
we were far
into the east bay for some participants
we were in the middle of oakland for
some participants so we try to get the
broadest socioeconomic distribution as
well as family distribution like for the
tv study we had people who lived alone
people who lived with couples people who
lived with kids
people who lived in multi-generational
households so whenever we do a study
with a dozen participants or so we
really want to make them as diverse as
possible
clearly you could get more diverse if
you got out of the bay area but we do
the best we can here and there are
professional recruiting firms that can
really help you get that diversity um
because it's you know often hard to have
ins in so many different communities to
to get people yourself
yeah i remember early on in the slide
presentation there was a
chart showing mobile use kind of
encroaching and surpassing tv usage i'd
be interested in like a similar thing
for internet usage because i feel like
in my personal life
mobile phone use is replacing some of
that it's curious
yeah i mean that is definitely a trend
so i mean sales of actual computers are
are going down right people are using
phones and tablets much more in their
lives um and also replacing those more
often as well
but yes definitely for the most part the
use of a typical computer a desktop or a
laptop is decreasing rapidly in most of
the population and phones are becoming
our primary way phones and tablets
together are becoming our primary way of
accessing the internet
do you have any data about
people are
more receptive for for ads for example
so when i'm when i'm waiting
for my coffee and mine
it might be more receptive than uh
when i'm using the phone for navigation
purposes something like that yeah so
this particular none of these particular
studies got into ads in particular uh we
do have scientists at yahoo who really
do study people's perceptions of ads um
henrietta kramer might be a good person
to talk to
and she's done a lot of work on kind of
the annoyingness of ads in various
scenarios um and so some of her work
might be might be interesting to you
i'd like to
maybe gently push back a bit on this
you know we can design better interfaces
to get people to spend less time on
their phones or like more effective or
efficient interfaces especially i feel
like there's been this narrative over
the past like 15 years where repeatedly
like information overload we need to
design better like better interface so
that we can consume more information
better and more efficiently so we have
more time to sit by the fireplace or
whatever
and my innovation sort of
without data honestly sure has been that
we make these more efficient interfaces
and what that allows us to do is we just
sort of increase the bandwidth of the
amount of information or the diversity
or information we take in it's like
great now i'm much more effective at
like consuming my twitter feed so i'm
also going to start browsing reddit or
something like this so i wonder if it's
i wonder if there's this this solution
needs to be a social solution rather
than sort of the yeah the bandwidth
solution no and i think you're starting
to see that i mean we were talking at
lunch a little bit about people who are
taking like phone holidays and you know
leaving turning off all their
notifications for weekends or you know
completely turning off devices for
various periods of time so i think some
of it is social and you need people to
sort of
come together and say maybe this isn't
what we want to be doing with all of our
time when we're together as a family on
the weekend
but i also think i mean if you have your
phone and you've turned on notifications
from all of your apps your phone is
vibrating like every 30 seconds right i
mean there's always something coming in
from some source
and that's that's too much right that i
think most people can agree that the
current way of notifications at least on
phones which is the thing that keeps
driving us in it every few minutes um is
broken and thinking of ways to better
notify people and somehow convey
importance um
or
at least kind of bulking things together
or and there's various strategies people
are building some prototypes and
exploring some of them there's some nice
papers upcoming at kai this year on
different kind of bulk notification
systems or
ways to actually mute notifications for
certain periods of time and i think that
kind of stuff will help us to
at when we want to put the phone away
and engage with each other and not be at
dinner with someone in every minute our
phone vibrating in our pocket and us
wondering what's going on what are we
missing out on
yeah uh-huh yeah
back there yeah
yeah so i was wondering uh so you were
saying that we spend three hours a day
on the phone and it takes away from our
interactions in real life so do you see
the
ambient display as something that'll
allow us to have um i guess just more of
a gaze of our environment environment
which includes people or yeah do you see
it as
and i mean this this way needs to take
us closer to
or needs to kind of simulate what real
life experiences would be
um rather than just
giving us more time to have the real
interaction yeah i mean i think the the
real
research directions of ambient displays
if we're if we're doing them well
they're things that are not distracting
us unless we should be paying attention
to them or we we desire to pay attention
to them um and there's been an active
research field for for decades now um
trying to design some of these things
and i feel like nobody's really hit on
the right display yet um you had you
know david rose's company ambient
devices that was making these color
changing orbs that you know you're sold
at brookstone for a while and things
like that
but it just didn't hit in a mass-market
way right
the umbrella that he made though that i
loved so it was an umbrella where the
handle lit up anytime you needed to take
it
and so if you just had it hanging by the
door
and you were walking out and it was lit
up then you needed to take it that day
and that was beautiful so i think things
that are more like that where
the objects in our lives tell us if we
need them or tell us if we need to pay
attention to them
it's just a much more natural way of
interacting with information then
putting it all on a big lit screen in
front of our face
john i was curious what you thought that
three hours of phone use is displacing i
mean yeah your data shows that the three
hours of phone plus three hours of tv
overlap so it's not a total
you know they do but what do you think
that three hours is this place yeah so
we know it's not displacing television
because the average has stayed the same
to a minute or two over the years
it's overlapping right but it's not
displacing it um
i think some of it is displacing
computer time right so you're not on
your computer as much um
but i think a lot of it is displacing
social time you know you're at a
restaurant how many times have you
pulled out a phone and looked at it
right we all have right
and um
that is that's the thing i'm most
concerned about it's just how how these
devices are
are just taking time away from the time
we're face to face with each other and
certainly a lot of this usage is
happening when we're in social settings
all right i'm not breaking he'll he'd be
here for more questions afterwards but
let's thank frank one more time
thank you
you